monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale mercredi dernier vous avez
partagé l'émotion des élèves et des
professeurs du lycée Saint Thomas
d'Aquin de Saint-Jean-de-Luz je vous en
remercie ce drama absolu n'a pas grand
chose à voir avec la violence qui
gangrène nos collèges et au lycée où la
difficile détection des situations de
détresse des adolescents de ces sujets
nous reparlerons quand l'émotion sera
passée pour l'heure je voudrais vous
narrer l'histoire d'un inspecteur
d'académie venu dans un petit village de
France calculer le nombre d'élèves
attendus pour la prochaine rentrée par
la fenêtre d'école plusieurs maisons en
construction devant accueillir dans deux
ou trois ans des familles avec enfants
mais ce qui se passera dans deux ou
trois ans n'intéresse pas Monsieur
l'Inspecteur d'Académie l'école à la
prochaine rentrée perdra trois élèves
trois élèves en moins un professeur en
moins une classe qui ferme tel est le
verdict ce rituel immuable qui sent bon
la Quatrième République la carte
scolaire rituel qui conduit chaque année
les aspectateurs académie de France et
de Navarre à sortir le règle à calcul
pour compter les élèves et décider du
sort des postes et des classes et
pendant ce temps l'état demande aux élus
d'inscrire leur politique d'urbanisme
dans les radettes Scott peluy ou plu
imposant au maire de voir loin monsieur
le ministre jusqu'à quand restaurez-vous
le seul de vos collègues qui adaptent
chaque année les postes au comptage à
l'unité près de ces usagers monsieur le
ministre accueille une procédure
pluriannuelle de la carte scolaire
adaptée à notre époque bref monsieur le
ministre au ministère d'éducation
nationale l'entrée dans la modernité
c'est pour quand
pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre